dédié à vos loisirs aux événements
culturels qui ont fait l'actualité de la
semaine écoulée dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de l'événement du
week-end je veux parler d'un grand
tournoi de poker qui aura lieu à magny
les hameaux alors amateurs de quinte ou
de fleuves à vos cartes et puis l'autre
évènement de ce week-end c'est un
concours de danse concours de danse
trophy qui va se dérouler à plaisir dans
la galerie commerciale d'auchan samedi
19 octobre un concours de danse national
ouvert à tous il ya très étape partout
en france à une seule en ile-de-france
était celle de plaisir et pour en parler
un chorégraphe est venu sur le plateau
de l'émission culturelle kiosque et on
les écoute ainsi que la présidente du
jury qui est forcément quelqu'un que
vous connaissez c'est mia frye on
écoutait le concept c'est un concours
concours national donc concours amateur
qui était ouvert à tous tout tout tout
dans cette catégorie amateur ça veut
dire que ce ne sont pas des danseurs
professionnels à toutes les écoles ont
fait appel en général les écoles et et
et autres des personnes qui sont pas
forcément dans un club mais qui qui
danse depuis longtemps ils peuvent
participer quel type de danse alors il
ya vraiment il ya vraiment eu de danse
ça va de la danse de couple
hip hop modern jazz danse classique
c'est vraiment tous styles de danse
l'objectif c'est de rendre partage et de
la danse avec tout le monde c'est à dire
c'est d'amener les gens à venir danser
avec nous partager un moment de danse et
ceux qui ne dansent pas ils peuvent ils
peuvent voir parce qu'il ya des
exhibitions tout le temps donc quand ya
pas de cours de danse ont fait des
démonstrations
est ce qu'on peut faire c'est écouter
les conseils de mia frye donc qui
préside le jury et qui va donc aussi
coacher les candidats dans les quotas la
sélection se fait par le coeur c'est à
dire faire partir du moment où on
s'aperçoit de quelqu'un ou un groupe est
vraiment dans son sujet dans une vraie
sincérité ce qui le range il raconté je
pense que forcément c'est cela qui me
donne envie de les choisir
il ya évidemment la licence elle il y a
le thème choisi il ya un costume qui à
la scénographie qu'on discutait les
graphiques sont à ces critères
voilà et puis si vous êtes amateurs de
danse h et vous pouvez encore vous
inscrire le samedi matin même à auchan
pour participer à ce concours danse
trophy aller déclic théâtre à 20 ans la
compagnie de théâtre d'impro a proposé
son fiesta qu'à la merise le trappeur
forcément tv fil 78 y était à la fois
pour capter l'ambiance
et puis recueillir le témoignage de ceux
qui sont passés par un trou trappistes à
figer un sujet signé aurélien de bissy
morteau c'est quand même la société doit
une petite société sa capacité
d'habitudes petites ficelles
on se retrouve demain on va converger le
truc notre déclic c'est sûr mais demain
après le déclic théâtre invente son fier
ce tacle jamais en manque d'imagination
la compagnie d'improvisation théâtrale
qui fête ses 20 ans a organisé samedi à
la merise de trappes son grand fiesta
khl une soirée de gala sous forme de
cabaret avec au programme du théâtre
d'impro go sûr mais aussi musique humour
instant d'émotion et retrouvailles je ne
demande sa patte ce soir le meilleur
souvenir parce que du coup on fait un
espèce de faire tourner à tout ce qu'on
a fait en 20 ans
c'est là on se dit ouah on a fait tiquer
dans quoi donc je pense à celui là qui
va rester une occasion de réunir les
talents de ce qu'ils font ou ont fait
déclic théâtre
parmi les anciens hills à doumbia et un
autre amer ils ont fait leurs premiers
pas dans la patinoire des déclics
et ce soir-là en de nouveau conquis les
spectateurs commissariat tout mon argent
courtois et de l'orienter rien on va
parler un problème posé également toutes
vos armes sur kombouaré 7 en sortant du
commun pour moi mon coeur que je me suis
fait cette petite chronique c'est une
compagnie qui a changé ma vie donc
moi je souhaite à déclic de changer la
vie de beaucoup d'autres personnes voilà
qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter ben 20
ans de plus et avec la même chose
franchement pas
nation pourquoi les 100 dollars à son
collage être absolument pas de tout à
coup de barre
j'ai beaucoup aimé parce que je connais
déclic depuis sa création et j'étais au
collège courbet j'enseignais donc je
connais bien j'étais très heureux d'être
là ce soir est très émue aussi beaucoup
de souvenirs parce qu'on est tous
impliqués en fait à un moment ou un
autre dans cette soirée on s'est
retrouvé donc super très contente
à part qui avait pas jamel debbouze
voilà la soirée a été magnifique c'est
l'absence marquantes
cette soirée celle de gamelles de figure
pourtant emblématique de la compagnie
découvert par son charismatique
directeur artistique tapis les papilles
en a qu'un
why en a un il y avait ici mais il y en
a pleins partout sur ma jambe dans
d'autres disciplines dans d'autres
domaines on l'a c'est une belle soirée
parce que c'est la fête de l'équipe j'ai
plus de voix parce que voilà c'est
l'émotion qui fait que ubuntu est un
moment il ya plus de monter une
compagnie qui dure 20 ans et c'est pas
une gageur c'était cet effort et je
pense qu'avec mélanie ya encore quelques
années devant devant elle et va
renouveler sa toute façon le lien avec
des clips le lien avec trappe pour moi
c'est juste que jusqu'au bout de ma vie
anti l'état
à aytré
la bonne anniversaire à déclic aller
l'université de versailles saint quentin
vient de terminer son festival art in
the city et parmi les démonstrations et
les animations proposées il y avait un
spectacle aérien alors regardez surtout
lever les îles
les fenêtres de l'université de
versailles saint quentin sont leur seule
tenue par un simple baudrier le long
d'un élastique ses danseuses modifie la
perception de l'espace et crée de la
hauteur
on a juste quelques cordes une danse
assez assez épuré et puis une histoire
que doivent s'inventer les passants un
travail de deux mois pour réaliser cette
performance
elle marche dans l'air suspendre le
temps scénique un fil élastique s'amuse
de l' architecture sous le regard de
leurs chorégraphies
ce qui me plaît c'est
ça vient d'un parcours moi j'ai d'abord
été grammer et donc quand on est
grimpeur et qu'on se balade
dans la ville on se rend compte qu'il ya
un nombre de l'espace possible
du tiff a utilisé pour le niveau de la
verticale qui est absolument énorme
un spectacle qui s'inscrivait dans le
cadre du festival universitaire are in
the city festival qui se termine le 18
octobre
maintenant passer un autre suisse a rien
à voir avec un spectacle aérien et
pourtant francs lyon je pense qu'il faut
aussi avoir les nerfs solides dans votre
discipline puisque on va parler d'un
tournoi de poker qui a lieu samedi et
dimanche à magny les hameaux gymnase
chantal mauduit donc pendant pendant
deux jours je me dis oui il faut
effectivement avoir les nerfs solides
pourtant les joueurs de poker bonjour
ouais c'est une des qualités requises
pour ce pour ce sport combien de joueurs
attendus on va peu à peu près 150
joueurs 150 joueurs sur deux jours est
ce que ce sont des joueurs qui sont
forcément inscrits en club
exemple des joueurs forcèment forcément
inscrits oncle pour ce pour cet
événement cet événement ci est alors
est-ce que 50 ans nuit est toujours
assez tiède voire assez importants
efforts d'ailleurs c'est pour cela qu'on
a appelé ce challenge challenge ssq y
saint quentin en yvelines
enfin magne event aussi parce qu'on
voulait parler de la commune de magny et
il repart enfin il comprend donc le club
de du ménage de voisins-le-bretonneux
qui est le plus ou moins grand frère de
tous les clubs delà de la région nous
ensuite on associe temps seconde wb th
de magny les hameaux et puis des frênes
ceux de montigny donc la vie nouvelle et
assez représentées sur sur ce tournoi si
quel type de poker en jouant on va jouer
à manille ce week-end plusieurs types de
poker si c'est clair mais celui ci c'est
le bas le poker principales autoroutes
en parlait depuis des années le texas
hold'em qui est un poker à deux cartes
et avec donc deux des joueurs
relativement guérit maintenant là où
deux bouts de cette année donc ça va
être un gros un bon tournoi je pense
juste patienter les spectateurs vous
allez faire plein de déçus mais on peut
pas venir toquer à la porte du
wales est rentré on va dire produire ici
de sécurité des soucis de sécurité
l'organisation
nous sommes obligés de limiter de
limiter des entrées à quelques visiteurs
ou accompagnateur de joueurs sinon on
était obligé de prendre d'autres
dispositions ces hausses seraient
rapidement trouve à 400 500 personnes
étaient présentes quand même c'est un
tournoi de poker et croyait du cil en
voilà voilà voilà on peut pas pour le
public ne peut pas se permettre de
passer entre les tables ou de supporter
ou de houe de fou de faire 2 août faire
du bruit quoi donc c'est ce qu'il ya de
l'argent en jeu c'est non non non c'est
tout pas surtout pas savoir pourquoi
parce que c'est vraiment pas autorisés
c'est pas autorisé au niveau que
lorsqu'on crée une association d'un
rendez vous avec avec des services de
l'état qui qui vous qui vous a des bien
ce qu'il faut faire et ne pas faire
et de toute façon c'est c'est dans un
but tu dis qu'après rien n'empêche à
titre personnel de dalles et d'alléger
joueurs ont des jetons il a une valeur
mais qui c'est une façon rien à vrai
dire
bon il faut amasser tous les jetons à la
fin il ya qu'il ya quelques lots on va
dire il ya qu'il ya quelques lots mais
c'est symbolique c'est réellement
symbolique par rapport à ces vraiment le
plaisir de se retrouver et puis depuis
deux ans on va dire le trophée plus
presque plus important que les lots il
ya une coupe qui est mise en jeu là qui
sur le sont pour les trois clubs de la
ville nouvelle qui sera remise en jeu
l'année prochaine on espère et puis nos
récompenses individuelles pour ce dès
qu'ils terminent premiers du tournoi
par contre on fait main on va travailler
avec des associations à une opération
caritative
c'est à dire ce tournoi quand même avec
deux buts le premier c'est que c'était
quand même rendre hommage à 1
un ami du club qui est disparu il ya
deux ans c'était une personne
relativement emblématique et sympathique
depuis donc ça fait la troisième fois
qu'on lui rend hommage en lui dédiant le
tournage octobre et là on a décidé de
l'agrandir
laurent allard 10-10 poussière et enfin
voilà donc on lui rend hommage par parle
par le biais de ce tournoi et l'ac ont
dû rendre plus complet quand on mange
avec en invitant d'autres clubs voisins
une opération caritative qui seront là
savoir nous faire les repas et puis un
petit spectacle le samedi seront
peut-être les sites est assez vivre au
village à la mecque et humanité tout à
fait vous êtes joueur je joue au soccer
vous est venue cette passion vous êtes
venus s il est vrai qu il est aussi
alors ça fait partie quoi ça fait partie
du 6 du joueur devant la seconde maman
importance à toi on pas forcément d'où
d'autres qui ont des lunettes doute
qu'ils écoutent de la musique d'autres
avec un tas de petits enfants après
avoir plein de choses sur sa table oui
donc c'est pas une chose imposant il y
en a qui ont une ribambelle de
ribambelle de passe assez impressionné
les adversaires parce qu'on vous en avez
non c'est noir enfin de la casquette et
lunettes c'est sûr tout est bon on peut
dire que ça peut impressionner
l'adversaire mais c'est pour aussi
cacher ses émotions
et puis il me puis surveiller un peu ce
qui se passe sans être vu aussi après le
gris s'est dégagé s'est passé c'est la
chance enfin où c'est de la superstition
je reviens sur les qualités quand même
d'un joueur de poker parce que il
s'offre aux débutants entretien on s'en
doute c'est quoi masquer ses émotions
d'abord en premier il y avoir de la
mémoire et à la patience il ya la
patience parce que
je suis très très peu de mains par
rapport aux mots main qui nous on jette
beaucoup de cartes par rapport aux mains
qui nous ont été distribués il ya la
patience il ya là la stratégie
il ya aussi la psychologie et puis
notamment l'ambiance à table dans la
psychologie c'est à dire que vous
regardez un petit peu et puis en pillant
ça tape s'il a pris ainsi un adversaire
après un gros coup juste avancée qui va
peut-être être fragilisés on peut
l'attaquer multiples fusent et puis bien
évidemment la chance qui fait partie
quand même hein il ya patrick bruel
aussi parce que c'est un grand joueur de
poker il reconnu il fit une pub où nous
dit en gros est ce qui compte au poker
c'est pas tant la qualité des cartes que
de savoir s'en servir vos ouailles envie
de dire quand même quand on a quatre
agents venus dans un jeu ça va être
comme moi évidemment c'est facile non
oui enfin c'est effectivement je trouve
que cette maxime est un peu un petit peu
d'être enfin décalé parce que c'est
vraiment les personnes aguerries qui
peuvent faire n'importe quoi et
n'importe quelle carte on va dire ça moi
ça ça dépend du déroulement du coup on
va dire si si si on fait effectivement
si on met toutes en jeu sans avoir vu
une carte mais la chance là va rentrer
en ligne de compte si on fait tapis tout
de suite on dit que si le coût se
déroule normalement jusqu'à l'abattage
des cinq cartes laon ça fait plus un
cadastre donc la patience la stratégie
et dernière question avait beaucoup
d'hommes qui joue en faveur quoi les
femmes s'intéressent pas où elles sont
pas si je sais tu pas pourtant on a on a
eu quelques représentants pour
l'attaquant van wel relativement forte
un tournoi pendant deux jours qui est
qui et on verra au gymnase dojo du
gymnase à magny-les-hameaux alors qu'il
n'est pas ouvert au public
si vous voulez avoir le résumé de ce
tour un rendez-vous dans le 7-8 actu de
lundi
viendra faire évidemment un reportage
merci à vous on va maintenant se tourner
vers la bande dessinée le festival de bd
de but bien de se terminer et l'occasion
pour nous de rencontrer un vrai
passionné s'appelle fille pleurait et
depuis 20 ans il a suivi toutes les
éditions du festival de buts
philippe est un abonné en vingt ans il
n'aura pas raté une seule édition de ce
festival de bande dessinée de buc
et comme chaque année ce bédéphiles
venue de cannes ne repartira pas les
mains vides
c'est une série qui fonctionne très bien
et ça plaît bien au public non moins pas
de temps à perdre philippe s'empresse
d'aller à la rencontre de l'auteur pour
la dédicace c'est un avantage de ces
festivals lorsque les auteurs sont sur
place
on a la chance de l'avoir
c'est fort sympathique de festival en
festival philippe nous de véritables
amitiés avec ses auteurs favoris comme
régric françois copé
donc depuis 23 ans
et puis voilà donc ça permet de voir
l'évolution moteur aim à merci
merci orvin
donc il a fait celle-ci voilà donc celle
là il a fait un personnage
il n'a pas fait le héraut là c'est un
personnage de l'histoire c'est le
professeur vers d'ailleurs
aarhus et puis voilà et puis là il a
doublé en 20 ans en rajoutant un qui
petite dédicace personnalisée
alors j'ai à peu près l'ensemble de mes
bd j'en ai un peu près 1500 tous
confondus
tout confondu avec les époques et j'en
ai à peu près 900 dédicacer ce qu'il
affectionne tout particulièrement c'est
la bd franco belge des années 50 à 70
une passion qu'il vit depuis plus de 50
ans c'est pas comme aujourd'hui c'était
pour la même époque les histoires
étaient plus saine et elle était très
bien très bien dessiné très bien très
bien conçu et tout le monde pouvait lire
ces bandes dessinées à partir de
l'enfance jusqu'à la période adultes
c'est ce qui m'a toujours plu j'ai été
élevé avec le journal tintin journal
spirou d'époque
alors vous imaginez aujourd'hui et j'ai
accumulé toutes ses histoires ses albums
que l'on a à faire
donc je suis arrivé aujourd'hui à une
belle collection qui prend beaucoup de
place beaucoup d'argent
surtout de la place de la place il va
encore en falloir pour ces nouvelles bd
et on avait déjà les éditions originales
mais aujourd'hui il a acheté une
réédition avec les nouvelles couvertures
c'est une bonne occasion c'est simple
voilà sans savoir lire et comprendre la
bande des six voilà voilà une rencontre
très sympathique signé à geleen thorez
et j'en attends un willeman aller le
portrait de la semaine il est signé
anthony rech
alors notre journal ce sport a rencontré
pascal boulanger c'est un pilier deux
fois c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire
regardez l'histoire entre pascal
boulanger le rugby cherche toujours le
retour aux sources comme la relation
vitale entre un talonneur et son pilier
en mêlée le pack le saint quentinois s'y
frotte pour la première fois à l'âge de
9 ans à montigny au poste de deuxième
ligne
repéré par carcassonne chez les juniors
il tente sa chance dans la cathédrale
des avants le centre de formation de
bourgoin jallieu
mais loin de ses attaches le colosse ne
trouve pas ses repères et revient au
bercail après quatre petits mois je les
assume complètement
j'ai progressé en étant là bas et j'ai
vécu une aventure que j'avais à vivre et
voilà maintenant je suis content de
l'avoir fait je regrette pas mais je
suis content d'être entré aussi il
aurait pu s'amuser en championnat de
france
mais le pilier saint quentinois de 19
ans tenait d'abord à remercier son club
formateur mochis ni c'est le club qui
m'a formé et que je leur devais au moins
un minimum une saison l'équipe senior
pour les remercier tout simplement et
pour essayer de faire quelque chose vu
qu'on était en 1ère série nous pour
essayer de monter en promotion d'honneur
ça c'est pas fait malheureusement
j'aurais aimé quitter le club en montant
philibert avait déjà repéré ses qualités
physiques chez les jeunes vu le
potentiel du gamin 1 m 87 % 25 kg sur la
balance
le staff plaisir roy va devoir faire des
pieds et des mains pour conserver son
pilier grosse abnégation c'est quelqu'un
qu'on vend pas beaucoup qui parle pas
beaucoup mais qui fait le travail
et puis après physiquement c'est une
certaine c'est une mue coin
il avance sur tous les impacts heures en
défense ils trains etr à rien et quand
il avait une salle dans un maul dans un
ruck pour faire un contrepoids que ça se
voit bon joueur de ballon passe om
longer la touche et inscrire comme lors
de la dernière journée 2 essais en bout
de ligne il fait d'ailleurs partie des
meilleurs marqueurs du prc ou très bonne
intégration il assimile très très vite
les que les combinaisons
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui est très très
bien aussi bien sur le terrain que
humainement parlant
en dehors du terrain et franchement
c'est que du plaisir d'évoluer à côté de
voir comme ça surtout pour renforcer
l'équipe et atteindre l'objectif qu'on
s'est fixé cette année quoi la montée en
fédérale 2 pascal boulanger il pense à
chaque match le coût serait parfait pour
sa première saison sous les couleurs du
prc le succès là où tout a commencé
car paso n'est jamais aussi bon que
lorsqu'il revient aux sources
voilà pour ce portrait de la semaine
vous savez le week-end vous pouvez aussi
aller au cinéma et chaque semaine à un
directeur de salle de saint quentin en
yvelines donne son coup de coeur et
cette fois place à gatineau c'est le
directeur du grenier à trappes
on écoute cette semaine au grenier à sel
je voudrais vous proposer le film elle
s'en va c'est un road movie réalisé par
emmanuelle bercot à l'histoire du film c
betty une femme qui a passé la
soixantaine tout s'écroule autour d'elle
son amant saura sont à son restaurant se
casse la figure
daba claque la porte elle prend la
voiture va faire un tour de pâté de
maison et puis ce petit tour se
transforme en échappée et tout est
prétexte pour ne pas rentrer et ça dure
comme ça donc c'est un film de rencontre
un film de réconciliation aussi avec sa
fille c'est
l'actrice principale c'est donc
catherine deneuve et marisa prisme
anadarko dit ce film a été fait pour
catherine deneuve et ça a été le moteur
du film on retrouve aussi on notera un
autre acteur on retrouve camille la
chanteuse camille qui joue la fille de
catherine deneuve
on retrouve aussi à dire hier si on
retrouve mylène demongeot et paul ali
qui est le contre bientôt dans un film
avec sara forestier qui s'appelle risque
qu'on retrouvera dans nos écrans dans
quelques mois la réalisatrice donc
emmanuelle bercot
on connaît peu son nom et pourtant elle
a fait beaucoup d'autant que
réalisatrice et en tant qu'actrice et
notamment en tant qu'actrice on a vu
dans carlos d'olivier assayas
on l'a vu dans les petits mouchoirs on
l'a vu dans police qu'elle a coécrit
avec maïwenn et est donc ce film là elle
s'en va et c'est un de ses premiers
longs métrages en a fait deux ou trois
il semble donc c'est un film auquel on
tient beaucoup au grenier à sel quand
vous invite à venir voir et vous
retrouver les horaires vous pouvez
regarder sur www.cinematheque.fr pointe
comme voilà merci et gaëlle du vernis à
c'est la trappe
les élèves des écoles élémentaires de
tra pour participer à la semaine du goût
au menu des produits issus de
l'agriculture biologique ou alors encore
des produits locaux le but les
sensibiliser à une cuisine équilibrée et
de qualité mais aussi peut-être leur
faire oublier les traditionnelles frites
pas facile du potage de potiron un filet
de hoki avec un mélange de chou fleur
voilà un menu raffiné que les enfants de
l'école jean cocteau découvre avec
quelques hésitations devant l'assiette
du poisson avec les brocolis c'est du
show plaît pas souvent chez moi on en
toute la semaine ces élèves trappistes
mangent des produits bio locaux sous
forme de jeu ils apprennent l'importance
des fruits et légumes et d'un menu
équilibré mais à la maison leurs plats
préférés restent bien loin de cette
cuisine diététique le fric des rabots
lasagnes
la semaine du goût tente d'inciter les
enfants à une alimentation de qualité
car à la cantine
gare aux petits gourmets qui ne finit
pas son assiette
on est environ entre 90 et 120 grammes
par enfant de rejet de produits de
cliquer consommé sur 800 grammes à peu
près de produits par enfant c'est
d'arriver à phénomène du groupe a évolué
ces phénomènes de groupe
l'enfant qui dit j'en veux pas et les
autres qui disent ah bah oui moi non
plus au vu des assiettes vides ce repas
dit d'automne a tout de même plus aux
enfants qui n'ont pas laissé une miette
7,8 ce week-end est terminé merci de
votre attention je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end très bientôt
oui